obviously congratulations to man you're
going to be starting on uh season two of
uh raising canaan
i feel like i knew this [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] from the show
that [ __ ] made the television make you
look biggest you're 15 pounds heavier
[ __ ] look bigger
i was 13 pounds heavier but yeah i'm
still a little ass then compared to you
mike
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson i
am your co-host triple c aka henry
cejudo and i'm mike tyson the champ and
we have our brooklyn homeboy here joey
badass talk to us baby joey
man
talk to us man thanks for having me glad
you're having you bro
what about your new album out you have a
new album coming out soon yeah it's on
the way right now um
still finishing it up working on
finishing touches out here now like
produce your music do i produce it you
produce yourself i'll say our executive
producer you know like i i i give it the
direction yeah you're involved yeah yeah
heavily heavily always involved i've
always been hands-on with my yeah yeah i
don't train alone i mean
anyway right
what's up you know how old are you
probably 26 26 it's the baby from what
part of booking you from grew up so
i lived in flatbush pretty much i was
about 17 years old but i grew up in best
style like that's where
the school you went to out there so i
went to
i went to ps 135 elementary school then
i went to
the left for school in crown heights and
then i went to edward morrow high school
i want to um i want the ps3 um 170 154
ps54 you went to 54 yeah right on no
[ __ ] yeah my mom's went there
notion the heart street yeah
notion
that's crazy
yeah we used to live on our street too
yeah that's crazy
yo man he went to 54.
pretty crazy for you and mike like
coming from like pretty much the same
city man you gotta say yeah the same
stuff same same lifestyle so you went to
54 but you grew up in brownsville though
yeah
i'm i'm really from um let's die okay
we're gonna come to the hospital
yeah fort green you probably know my
uncle's man yeah they from the 70s
mm-hmm
yeah so that's what's up joey joey so
you're you started writing poetry man
that's kind of how you discovered like
hip-hop all like uh
mm-hmm
started um
i remember i was in uh what grade was
that first grade and i got introduced to
poetry and i immediately made the
connection like oh this is what biggie
doing you know cause like growing up in
my household my my parents was avid
hip-hop listeners like my mom they
listen to all types of music you know
all kinds of music it was a diverse but
hip-hop was definitely one of the
you know dominant genres of music we
listened to and being that we was from
brooklyn there was a lot of biggies a
lot of j so when i got introduced to
poetry in first grade it was like oh
this is what like my idols is doing like
you know with the rhyming world it
starts out with the vanguards in the
1400s and 1300s and stuff and the guy
just rhyming outside of the king's
castle
there's a vanguard there called them and
they would do that is like rapping but
they just be rhyming about what happened
today with the queen that's cheating on
the king the dope and all that yeah it
would be like little uh like comedy
almost right like or that's where the
rapping comes from yeah what'd you hear
about this sir how'd you know about this
when you look at the show king henry and
all that stuff you see people outside
the castle you know like revolting
saying this and this and my my family
my castle has been taken away and i'm
just my bloodline is this and the king
took away everything the flow was
definitely different but yeah but it
means the same it's a message being put
out there
facts the concept is definitely the same
yeah so the upbringing man with uh talk
a little about your upgrade man how was
it uh being raised in
in new york and you're saying
i'm from the best city on earth you know
that's how i look at it new york is a
very diverse place
capital of the world you know capital of
a lot of things in the world at that um
money capital of the world
money capital music capital you know a
lot of cabinets that's what i'm saying
style style capital everything
everything you know so being raised
is the modern day rome
or that order you know we're being from
brooklyn it was like a melting pot of uh
the west indies oh you i was gonna see
you from west indian jamaica yeah yeah
jamaica and my mom they all live in the
same
neighborhood
vanderveer you know vanderville
i grew up not too well i lived not too
far from van der veer i was on schneider
in 34th and the people up there i was
younger yeah
tell us a little bit about the uh the
whole pro era man tell us a little bit
about that shirt yeah thanks brother
just dancing
yeah
[Laughter]
did you always know as a kid that you
were different man do you think do you
think were you made or you think it was
a natural blue that you had since you
were a kid you're talking about first
grade you know what i'm saying um i can
tell you as an athlete as a as a
wrestler like i knew mike and you
probably knew this too mike you knew you
were different right you knew your
respect yeah that's a fact i definitely
knew that i was different growing up i
was the only child in my household so
that already allowed me to be
independent you know like uh i never
followed anybody growing up you know
like i
my cousins and you know my family had
families who was in the streets so that
[ __ ] was like right there that was easy
to me absolutely for me it was like you
know and then you know there was there
was like the right big homies almost
because like they pushed me away from
that like yo you focus on your school
thing focus on whatever else you want to
focus just don't be over here like we
over here we got this [ __ ] locked down
this [ __ ] is easy so that's kind of how
i always grew up and um you know i just
took my own path man like i always
just did what i wanted to do you know i
was i was just always the leader kids
followed behind me and things like that
in school so
yeah but was there like a particular
like switch do you think like all right
i was at this age when i j i just knew
that it was uh you know what i'm saying
well it was it was from the beginning
dude it wasn't
from the very beginning here like uh
when i was a kid
i want to say i was like eight years old
nine years old when i told myself by the
time i turned 21 i'm gonna be a
millionaire
like that's how i thought as a kid you
know what i mean it's like i just
and then i'm back
i grew up in the age of the internet as
well
so
for me
like i like i always say i went to
youtube university graduated with my
masters maybe even my doctor's day
you say youtube youtube university for
sure you know like youtube gave me a lot
of essentials to life um information
information uh skills and tools that i
still use to this day you know what i
mean
sure right right man what about you for
you mike when was it the the first time
you laced up a pair of boxing clothes
did you know
13. yeah but did you know mike that this
was like boom by the time you got in
there did you yeah
i just knew i could fight even though i
was scared i could fight i'd be like but
i'll stop boom knock the guy out back
i'm like um what was that baby huey you
know i looked this way at 12. what made
you throw the gloves on huh what made
you throw the gloves on i was i was
locked up in this juveniles joint and um
i got shipped to the you know lockup
dorm you know me and then this guy
this guy was boxing with kids on the
other side i see i want a box and he
started teaching he knocked me out first
and then he better teaching me how to
box there and then um i got better than
him and then one day i had broken nose
and i thought he was mad at me but he
was mad cause his wife said i don't want
you to box him no more that's why he was
mad so don't worry i'm gonna take you
somewhere and this guy's gonna take you
to the next level and that's how i met
my mentor cuss and i went to the next
level
wow [ __ ] but the thing is you know what
the crazy thing about it mike is what
your story is
man you had the cream of the crop right
away um there's a reason why you became
the youngest heavyweight champion of all
time yeah you know why
because i had to um
be humbled
life had to humble me
can you imagine what i thought i was at
20 years old the champ of the world yeah
you imagine my ego
yeah nobody can talk to me
so god had to humble me
i can deal with that too because i could
take it just as well i could give it
okay now mike you're talking about
humbling like you're talking about after
you you became a champion you were
humbled absolutely what was your first
like humbling experience you think like
you was on top of the world world
champion what was the first thing that
hit you losing people i loved
my friends are dying i'm the champion
where i'm a big chef but i can't save my
best friend from odin
of being shot depression and [ __ ] like
that where yeah
similar experience happened to me too
when i was 17 i lost one of my best
friends he to
suicide that's tricky too
we all have that feeling
i've thought that many of times we all
have that feeling creative minds that's
when i was um put polarity i was reading
this book and i was saying most of the
creative minds go that dark route when
they stop creating
that's why we hear a lot of people who
are creative people hurt themselves
there's something that goes on and says
i'm no good i'm no good anymore i can't
create
jesus it's almost like this right it's
like you always need a goal or have a
purpose to look forward to no no
no no i mean look at it
man um
man's a compound of needs and
necessities that could never be
satisfied and at any time when they do
seem to appear to be satisfied you know
they're bored in this you know the
they're bored
yeah
is it ego no it's just some
some individuals
they're the greatest of all time but
they got that big hole in them they
can't get full it's a void
you know they can't feel that hole yeah
how how do you feel that whole mic oh
the inside job but you know he can't get
nothing out here to do it mm-hmm
inside
this is the this is this is the
dangerous neighborhood in the world
going right here this is the dangerous
neighborhood in the world baby
forget brownsville compton or this is
the most dangerous neighborhood in the
world to be hanging out there [ __ ]
yeah you're right man cause that's what
that's where you spend the whole time
right i mean i imagine you really gotta
dig into your to your brain to freestyle
come up with these lyrics you know what
i'm saying like it ain't i always say
like i'm the type of person
i got so many tabs open in my brain you
know what i mean so it's like if we
don't take that time to compartmentalize
thoughts and ideas feelings emotions
moves it's like that [ __ ] starts to
consume you you know i mean you start to
lose control of yourself yeah so you got
to take that time to center yourself to
uh sit in silence a lot of people have a
hard time
sitting in science
evaluation know why is that brother
because we have to do that what we avoid
most of our lives doing they have
there's some self um reflection
face yourself
you know you got to walk down you got to
walk down that one street in this tough
neighborhood that you've been avoiding
for so long you know what i mean yeah
okay come on [ __ ] you're coming this
way yeah it talks bad to you
[Music]
masscapes are here to make sure you
don't carve your pants pumpkins when
you're grooming if you know what i'm
saying make sure you're keeping things
fresh this fall with leaders in male
grooming and their brand new fourth
generation performance package in the
performance package 4.0 you find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker
the ear and nose hair trimmer the crop
preserver the ball deodorant the crop
reviver tuner performance baller brief
and travel bag to hold all your goodies
first off new performance package 4.0
includes a new lawnmower 4.0 their
fourth generation trimmer features a
cutting edge ceramic blade
to reduce grooming accidents thanks to
advanced skin safe technology it also
gives you the ability to turn the 4000k
led spotlight on and off when needed for
more precise shave plus
it's waterproof
the performance package 4.0 also
includes a weed whacker to drop your
worst weed up your own nose and ears
seal the deal with baskets liquid
formulations the crop preserver ball
deodorant everyone knows pumpkin spice
lattes and ball deodorant go hand in
hand manske's doing two free gifts on
their performance package 4.0 the
manscape boxes and shed travel bag gets
comfy on the home and on the go this
season boys get ready for cuffing season
like no other ready to take the leap
into fall with keep join the 2 million
men worldwide using mass case by going
to manscape.com
hotboxing that's right go to
manscape.com
hotboxing tell them mike sent you
[Music]
mike do you think that's part of you
filling some of that voice like what
what you know what what joy badass just
said is it
you know reflecting on yourself you just
say joey like saying like seeing the new
it's my insecurities
my fears that i can't be what i'm you
know i mean my highest potential has
been
you know
i gave a lot of my life away to nothing
and i wondered can i really you know can
i really get this [ __ ] back again yeah
when you say nothing you gave your your
life away to nothing what do you mean by
that
that was the nothing part
i waste it
and i have i mean i waste a minute i
wasted your time right is that what it
is well
that's the only thing we don't have
enough of time yeah i waste a lot of
that
and if i would because it was all i
wasted was negative energy if i were to
do that negative energy and i had this
energy
my life would have been different my
life is awesome now but myself
um
my self-evaluation of myself would be
different
but it's been those experiences right
it's been those experiences that have
also
made you to the person that you are now
my you know they're called adversity
yeah you know i mean struggles
it's just what we have to do with human
beings we respond to the hardest
struggle which one is going to break us
that's our test word up yeah
adversity they got different breaking
points too you know
our adversities mike are virtually the
biggest blessings we could have as
humans absolutely
because adversity makes the strong
stronger and the weak weaker
and separates the two what's your take
on that joe
it reminds me of uh that chapter and the
48 laws of power when they say uh you
know if you don't got enemies
you know what i mean it's gonna
challenge you it's gonna keep you on
your toes if you don't got that then
it's going to be easy for you to fold or
to fold or something you know what i'm
saying you ain't going to have your
guard up you know you're going to get
hit with that that hook clean a man
that's a friend of everybody's an enemy
to himself or that yeah
yeah because it's almost like this i
always remember you talk about it mike
you're like yeah you lost your
nose but you lost your first amateur
fight
right it was that adversity who would
have known that kid that lost his first
damn that should turn into a monster
listen
there's some guys that people don't know
it's all about confidence you know you
could have a bad month back two years
and then boom oh why i won wow and i
didn't look bad let me try a little bit
harder but whoa i went again and you
might get 10 fights in the the champions
league have to take that bump he got
knocked out a bunch of times he had a
10th street outlet and then he knocks
the champ out
and that same guy don't lose for [ __ ]
eight years
hmm
confidence
yeah confidence goes a long way
a piece where you saying um every time
you got in that ring you were scared of
the other guy absolutely this you should
be scared this guy wants to hurt you
right it's very scary
yeah scary thing nobody's a tough guy
you know some people are tough but they
they're not gonna say i don't care who
you are how bad you are avoid you if you
say you're not afraid and then you're
lying or not lying that confidence
covered that because yes it's hard to
tell truly absolutely you have
confidence
confidence
brief success success preach confidence
absolutely confidence applied properly a
super theater genius
nothing like confidence
what do you think is the difference
between confidence and arrogance they're
in the same family right they're in the
same family joy can i get that again
would you say the difference between
confidence and arrogance oh
because you know i feel like some people
don't know how to distinguish between
the two it's not a distinguish between
them it's just um
the delivery right it's delivery that
makes it
arrogance and this sometimes the
delivery that makes a confidence the
only thing that matters is the results
no matter if he's the [ __ ] or he's
come with it the results right he says
i'm the best he proves he's the best
he's the best
so
yeah
why is that something that you uh that
you that you struggle with like the
confidence and the arrogance nah for me
i feel like i've always been um you know
since i was a kid i've always been
confident and i've always uh kind of
made a distinction between confidence
and cockiness
and to me it's more like confidence is
something that
comes from inside you know once you do
that inner work arrogance is more like
it's about other people you know what i
mean
it's like it's like oh i'm i'm better
than you all well confidence is more
like
i'm the best it's all a form of love
all of that's a form of love
all that the fear the insecurity
all that stuff just to love i don't want
to fail if i feel they may not love me
isn't that so ridiculous we think that
that we think so much as we feel people
are gonna make people's lives over but
it appears like it is when you do lose
they lose everything they might bet
money on you right right they take you
serious most everything you take
yourself right seriously they put you a
lot their life on you you're fighting
they bit their life
isn't that crazy yeah but you know fans
and you know the people the bystanders
that they're all so fickle at the same
time too you know i mean it's like
sometimes people forget
that you're human
almost you know they forget that you
have the same only you have to remember
that that's not them that's not their
child remember their job is to make your
jobs make them smile and stuff but you
not to get involved personally with that
true
that's that's that's we can't we can't
let out here get in here once we get the
[ __ ] out here getting here we've been
gone
you ever missed your tiger huh yeah or
big time
because um
i have kids not small kids now he
wouldn't like that but yeah i miss my
cat
i could imagine i couldn't imagine yeah
they show off i haven't in my car do you
ever think about getting another one no
i have my kids a little oh
my god
he's having my rolls with me chilling
out and [ __ ]
yeah your older kids don't mike did you
your older kids were there when you had
your wife yeah they liked them they
loved them yeah
wouldn't you how long how long did you
have to get rid of him before uh like 14
years wow for how long 14 years for 14
he's
years
alive no i think he died they didn't
live long
they hit the eyes and the hips back
what's his name oh her name [ __ ]
kenya kenya
how many pounds of me did she eat
she didn't eat a lot but she she ate
constantly she had a lot constantly she
said you know you couldn't feel like one
time she
she likes to eat a lot
because she um chicken
chicken in there
oh some horse horse what they love more
than anything the horse or the chicken
what what is it about the horse meat
that makes it taste beautiful
beautiful you ever taste sauce before
i think maybe once
sorry
a little muscle yeah i never had horse
before what do they call horses in like
the grocery store
horse
i never seen that watch me if it comes
it's not like like a loaf of bread but
it's um it's cold they keep it in the
freezer and this big they just cause
it's hard because i know like deer meat
is like venison yeah that's beautiful
too yeah i think of that
oak um
the ox is good too alexa oh y'all love
some monster yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh
yeah i had to i put it to the office it
was turned out it was sick they loved it
yeah what is this mike
it's
there's that confidence they are they
all good
you do a lot of rap freestyle like rap
battles
um no i i ain't never really battled
like that growing up but we were super
competitive like
with my crew when we was in height oh
yeah you see those first two fire
first two though the whole lineup right
there i'm telling you the little [ __ ]
that's down there from around your way
that was locked up they're trying to get
them out what's his name again who
that that's that [ __ ] song the bad
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what's that
bad [ __ ] what's that [ __ ]
yeah
oh he out now yeah you saw him yeah yeah
yeah yeah facts we we about to make it
yeah that should be slick right yeah
yeah yeah i'm happy that carries out man
not
yeah
yo tell em we back in this one of a
conspiracy be remembered with the times
of disguising limits bitchin billy in my
prime this ain't half a division and i'm
uh i'm mentally in the prison i'm a man
on the mission until i'm out of
commission got my mama be trippin
thought i'd be bringin the children
instead i brought in a million a new
house in the millions [ __ ] i'm trying
to raise kissing yeah yeah warm up i
said first off how can i say this so
politely [ __ ] the publications dog they
don't really like me took me out the
conversations never did invite me in any
allegations that's the wire unlikely
true and i got way more to prove but
it's a statement or two to be said for
such wings to do so i've been patient
too made me more ill though for real
name another brooklyn cat major without
a deal i destroy average rappers just
practice eat them up for breakfast being
savage a habit [ __ ] i didn't had it
been across the atlas been back and even
bent backwards now i got it mastered for
ten thousand hours and every minute
after it's another chapter forty seven
dollars to power over two hundred fifty
thousand albums so world wideness ain't
even half the potential i possess vessel
i reflect look me in the opposites of
god in the flesh rules and resurrected
what they so called protected now
matching necklace like a diamond feel
pressure time is so precious definitely
up for essence they told me quit
reminiscing get with the president's
soul i switch it up to no styles they
heard before not necessarily before
ain't no challenge i'm a pro [ __ ] yeah
i've been a beast with these flows
killing these foes praying on my
downfall interrupt the reign deal with
the downed poet said something about you
lames when you aim me down below the
drama won't let up your wreath with your
soul men lie with my line number short
though got the whole beast ghost coming
for your skull the karma gonna catch up
the album sales won't
just one up my collar gone show holler
back when you getting 60 stacks for the
show that worried about the clubs i
worried about the love ball it looks so
big yeah but just get it none what is
getting sun they can use a hug i do
direct shots never subs only catch l's
y'all only face doves now i might as
well go ahead and put the plug on these
[ __ ] said this
you want some more
wait you ever do k slang okay slay i
don't think i got a k-slate freestyle
out there but shout out to k-slay that's
my man
think you can have a mickey mouse oh
i mean shout out to the queen man you
know i would love to uh work with nicki
minaj green babysitting green
elaborating yeah man so you know i mean
obviously congratulations to man you're
gonna be starting on uh season two of uh
raising canaan oh
[ __ ]
50 [ __ ] right yeah yeah yeah
you mean you been tuning in
i know it's going up
yeah yeah that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is the you
know it's the best power it's the best
power so far yeah i ain't saying that
just because i'm on it i kind of am but
you know you the [ __ ] always shooting
[ __ ] always talking to his mom the moms
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] made the television make you
look biggest you're 15 pounds heavier
[ __ ] look bigger
i'm probably not i'm not to be fair i
was 13 pounds heavy i kind of like you
know [ __ ] me down and [ __ ] moving around
and all yeah but yeah
i mean i wouldn't fight heavy weight you
know man be like what what's your weight
170 on a good day heavy weight light
heavy weight yeah 175 pounds
how's it been how's the acting the
transition from you obviously from you
know being a freestyle artist to uh it's
just like
rapping
that's how i look at it man for real
you're being the person the personality
word up you know what i'm saying and
even with the lines and [ __ ] that's what
i do for a living is memorize lines you
know but also
i went to school for theater in high
school because you know music was always
my first passion it was my first thing
was about he was he was a he was a stage
cat
oh you know tupac oh yeah
yeah so yeah sort of like pop you know
park was a theater student as well for
me it was just like when i was leaving
middle school i knew i wanted to rap i
know i wanted to make music but there
was no schools that specialized in that
you know like rap music or hip-hop and
[ __ ] so i had to pick up on the next
best thing that i loved to do and i was
acting you know cause i was a fan of poc
i was a fan of will smith and um yeah it
was kind of like my idols or whatever in
addition to you know the rappers that i
looked up to so i auditioned for this
school i got in i mean i got kicked out
of the theater program like sophomore
year but
i still absorbed what i learned and um
i started to focus back on music because
i seen how hard the acting [ __ ] was
especially coming out of new york and i
just knew
if i if i got successful in my music
career i could leverage it as an actor
in the future yeah and here i am
leveraging would you think you would be
able to if you started acting and then
leveraging two no that's harder yeah
that's harder
to do anything you say there's only
obviously you said it was hard well
this is true but also just based on
historically it's harder for actors to
trans to to transition into music than
it is for musicians to transition into
acting yeah you know just like athletes
athletes could turn out to be better
actors than some actors that's what we
do that's what we do
every moment of our life is an act you
know that's just what it is performance
yeah you know performance-based art
entertainment yeah you're right
memorization of combinations of feel
it's a sense of act
it's a sense of uh recognition
you look like you just had a whoa
that type of moment you trying to act
like no no no
no no no and then you try active
something yeah i try to actually but
even me like i play a character you know
i played like the triple c character
it's just uh you know being being this
arrogant dude like the kind of fighter
to bring like uh you know notoriety into
whichever fight to get paper viewpoints
which you get more you get paid more
money but even like with me do like when
i go in there i gotta really like
like you know what i'm saying crazy eyes
freaking breathing
yeah exactly exactly
so some things like that but also like
fighting is a sense of not you mention
the mic it is a sense of acting right
you don't say we gotta we have to be
able to act like you hate this person
right yeah to beat the [ __ ] out of them
well you have to have emotional
intelligence you have to fight them like
you hate them but not actually hate them
i'm glad you mentioned that did you did
you read emotional intelligence what's
your book 2.0 yes the first one travis
bradbury and james that was pretty
interesting
i thought that listen i um i admire that
book you know a lot of people don't
think much about admire that book you
know they explain that emotional
intelligence is probably not 40 years
old this is a new word right the word is
very new and we never dabbled into our
emotional intelligence especially as you
know black men exactly we may find that
we're not as smart as we think we are
and that's not good either huh
but i i also think mike that that's the
reason why
you know there's two reasons why people
don't succeed
is because they think they're better
than what they really are or it's a lack
of confidence
no they don't succeed because they're
not meant for it
that's just what it is it's been written
yeah because you got you got a lot of
people who are super talented and they
just would never be successful because
uh i read this in rich dad poor dad like
they would never be successful because
my wife reads that [ __ ]
and the mentalist um
guru great to see what they're saying
like you know some people super talented
but they'll never be successful because
they won't allow themselves to learn new
skills
like uh
there's a section in the book where he
met this this author right and you know
he's he's uh robert kiyosaki he's he's
like the best selling author worldwide
but when he was explaining it to this
other author and she was like it's
almost like a lyricist
approaching um drake you know what i'm
saying and drake is literally don't get
me wrong but like drake was trying to
give the lyricist advice and lyricist is
like nah
that's weak because like i'm focused on
these lyrics while drake is like but you
gotta like like
you see the whole lesson was when you
come into the store it says best selling
author
not best author
not best writer you know what i'm saying
so the skill was marketability
sales you got to also have that not just
being not just being good at writing you
got to also learn the skills of sales
and marketing to
know how to hustle
emotional intelligence again because um
there's some guys that could um
kick my ass and they're sparring
training b didn't beat lettuce lewis be
anybody else in that ring sparring
but you know you get them in the ring
with around
20 000 people get some popcorn some
beers some life he panics uh-huh yelling
and she's rapping he might be like that
too right now he'll kill you but you put
some lights on put some fans in the
audience yeah
yeah that's that's when you're a man
they turn into it despite feeling that
way you can still perform everybody
can't perform with all those people in
these lights and they're getting some
popcorn it's not gonna work i'm serious
that sounds funny they have popcorn
eating the hot dogs it ain't gonna wait
anybody's looking at you just looking at
you like entertainment
i imagine the same thing with basketball
like when i used to play basketball as a
shorty like in the gym i would go hard
but when it was time to hit that park
i'm missing the easiest and they're
talking [ __ ]
i'm throwing air balls and showing oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] killing me
that's how i knew basketball wasn't for
me because i couldn't take that
commentary man i couldn't i could not
that brutal bad news i'm just making
music i'm sticking my music oh yeah so
mike mike when you talk about emotional
intelligence like is is that is that
what you think that's what's made you
successful then like you knowing that
you he uh joey brought it up earlier you
know you would be scared like going into
the room i like to think my fear made me
successful
the fear being nobody the fear of being
average the fear of going back to
brownfield it was like laughing at me it
was like your adversary your fear
my best friend mm-hmm
yeah but your mind is not your friend
you know that right your mind is not
equipped to do anything nice for you
unless you have it under control
it wants to kill you rather have you
miserable but and it will kill you too
your mind but it's almost because
because the brain is almost like that
you don't you think that's the same
reason why it's just it's just part of
life man it's just you have to learn how
to play this game called life right
especially through the mind
but nobody knows the game nobody ever
conquered the game of life
but maybe that's the game
i feel like life and like life here on
earth is like a school for your soul
no no life this is this whole big world
of school is a
yeah this is a big school yeah earth is
a school for you one big school you know
some of us learn quicker than others
like some of us get like animals some
animals get more domes get domesticated
earlier than others and some of you stay
animals and wild that's just how humans
some of us are like but it was difficult
to
you know
do you believe in like reincarnation and
stuff like that
i could
you know i think i'm i'm pretty western
that but i think i if i look at um
if i look at a
a bug or another spider i would think um
that could be my mother saying hey mike
it's me and me mike look it's me and i
go ugh
so i never kill anything anymore i don't
know anything
is that emotional intelligence oh check
this out mike yesterday joey i was uh me
and my girl were in the pool
and i saw there was this bee that was
struggling
and i was like and she was like no just
let her be like no dude's fighting for
his life dude so what i did is i grabbed
it you know through the water and i took
it out and i just watched it i just
watched how that little bee was
struggling do you know what it was like
they almost like lick each other like
they lick their toes or whatever like
they're very clean very clean yeah like
he was literally like recovering from a
beating you know this dude was about to
he was about to die
and it's just i thought i always wanted
to know this henry right because you
know sometimes i get um
i don't know what they call it but um i
always want to look at the birds i look
at the beetle i wonder what do they call
us what is the name that they use for us
terrorists
you know i wonder what they think of
animals i don't think it's it's more
like i think it's more of a vibration is
emotion you know what i mean i feel like
that's how insects or animals i think
animals are our consciousness like our
dog our dog knows when we're coming and
he didn't even hear us we'd be maybe um
five minutes two minutes before we come
in the house our dog went through the
door wait for us where did they know we
coming it's so far away smell yeah but
but even check this out too man because
this is how i see it now i don't know if
it's the toad i don't know if it's the
weed the mushrooms everything that we do
but you guys had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i did it for over 50 times with
the ayahuasca
come on well that's just what i said
that's what i said but the ceremony you
you have to sit we have to have a
relationship with god and then boom they
give it to you baby baby the ayahuasca
you talk about no the toes
it's like but it's like the same
chemical they're like the same you know
the high wasp was like 10 percent of
that oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] will
take cause you [ __ ] yourself that [ __ ]
yeah no i didn't no i did yeah your eyes
um because it kills your ego right you'd
be surprised how much you need your ego
you when your ego is going you're the
scariest [ __ ] in the world or whatever
so you just mommy when you're scared
you're gonna experience fear like you
never felt before but by 20 minutes
you're gonna be the happiest guy in the
world yeah it's like probably going
there free what did you do it i did it
and then i did it in mexico we said in
there
we got some guys mexico boarded in and
stuff
yeah i'm trying to try that [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] right here oh listen brother
you listen your whole rap game is going
to change yeah i'm trying to listen i
listen check this out it was on my
bucket list for [ __ ] last year but
then the whole pandemic [ __ ] happened i
was like 300 and something pounds i was
doing everything it's everything i did
the totally lost 100 pounds in four
months you know i'm fighting somebody
wow now i'm gonna do it again in
february can i do it with you hell yeah
[ __ ] we we know i know i'm gonna do the
toll probably next week sometimes i'm
gonna
fight another [ __ ]
the toes next week i'm a fighter
[ __ ] in february
i wanna i wanna do a two mic i gotta
deal with it i'm about to have a kid man
so i wanna i think that the the toad man
what's up he's gonna do anything [ __ ]
this is a tall man that hibernates 11
months or 10 months out of the year and
then you have you obviously have those
two months to catch it then you extract
the venom yeah yeah from it and then you
pretty much you smoke it oh you smoke i
thought you like kissed that [ __ ] no
that's that's just the wack way to say
lick it up no you got smoke
that i think mike
so you ever tried dmt
yeah right
dude that's about catching up dnp on the
high note
this is even higher than dmc
so what was your experience what did you
see what that feels because i've heard
experience i saw my ancestors like 10
000 years
wow you had a conversation and all that
no just watching and watching them
interact [ __ ] might be asian
there might be some
um some weird [ __ ] what's those
people like in um
australia right what's those black
people name over there come on
aberrations
from aborigines [ __ ]
damn yeah
those are adam and eve's people you know
let me ask you this mike what do you
think happens
like like after death after death
whatever you think happens happens
i believe everything we think is what we
are
brought up you know what i mean
whatever we say we are that's what we
are that's how come even though i play
games but i always go back and apologize
to myself with your mind
your mind don't know if you're playing
and i mean you feel like you're dumb
you're subconscious yeah you don't know
consciousness we be playing so i'm a
dumbass [ __ ]
subconscious don't know if you're
playing that's so true you want to be a
dumb [ __ ] all right we gotta run into
this accident in a few minutes that's a
fact i'm gonna show you we're gonna let
you hit that little girl dumb [ __ ]
i'm just saying yeah yeah now let's say
bad things about you i say that all the
time you know hopefully said that too
never say negative things about yourself
the subconscious don't know if you're
playing or not that's a fact i read that
in the positive part of your
subconscious mind yeah by joseph murray
one of the best books i've ever read
what's your favorite book you ever read
mike the prince
boy machiavelli yeah and it's really not
um
it's pretty primitive but it's just um
you can't it can't be escaped
it's who we are we want to be somebody
we want power and we get it by any means
necessary that's who we truly are
we are a bad lot and that's what it says
in the that's what it says from children
it's a power stroke human beings are a
bad lot
they're about what we're bad luck
race human beings are a bad race of
people
there's more bad than good enough but
check this out mike so anyways to get
back to that damn beast story is like
you analyze you look at whether it's a
dog or a damn insect
like we're no different than them no
no different than them we are them they
taught we are animals that were taught
to be human beings do you think you're a
[ __ ] human being
you think that's what you are a human
being you were taught to be a human
being you didn't start off your
ancestors started off as [ __ ] animals
like all the other beasts we got in
tribes we hunt down animals prehistoric
animals the [ __ ] woolly mammoth and
we ate these [ __ ] raw
and that's what we did
and then we um we kind of evolved more
we started getting cleaner so
you couldn't get you couldn't get sexual
diseases as much so um when when we
started cleaning ourselves
um ganga let's say let's say syphilis
used to be a a skin disease so we
started getting better hygiene and it
has a brain the the virus has the brain
so it wouldn't have value every year
yeah and so that's where it lives at
it's warming yeah but even like even
like because i feel like we can take a
lot from insects or even animals because
think about it think about how simple it
is they procreate like that's what
that's what these like you know like if
a man ain't having us you know sexual
sex with his wife like dude that causes
friction if you think about it with with
insects you know just real quick with
animals in general
like that's what they that's what these
people do all the time
no no listen they don't do it all the
time they only do it when a certain
season
like if a tiger sees another tiger and
it's not the [ __ ] season somebody's
gonna die
because you're gonna you're gonna
interfere with my [ __ ] food [ __ ]
it's not like oh you're fine i'm a man
you gonna eat the food together i'm only
gonna hunt for you me you're gonna stay
together for life no
you're a predator we're not breathing
we're fighting right for tigers but
that's what i'm saying so maybe that's
what it is maybe you see it i don't know
if you don't know what the tiger doesn't
know
you don't let that distract look you
don't let that take away from your life
look at us we get a wife and they think
that we got a family we like the the
lion we got a bunch of [ __ ] we got
girls we got responsibility the male
titans will have no [ __ ]
responsibility to [ __ ] kill so do you
think now mike as us as humans do you
think we belong together with somebody
or do you think we belong more like that
tiger way of everybody on their own kind
of we have to evolve to be better
individuals than we were the generation
before us we must continue to evolve and
involve to the highest point of thinking
you know be your best person you could
possibly be i want to ask you this mike
you know speaking of
sexual energy and things like that
you're familiar with semen retention
obviously explain it too so you know
just the whole process of
holding on to your yeah your essence you
know did you do that a lot before your
fights
yes
not because i thought it helped me
because other great fighters did and i
wanted to be able to be like them if
they can do it and that made them great
i have to do that too
how do you feel that it affected you how
do you feel like it affected your life
it didn't affect me
it's not the this is what i found out
from the old trainers the old trainers
didn't mind if you got some [ __ ] but
they didn't want you chasing [ __ ] they
didn't want you all night [ __ ]
chasing [ __ ] now you got to come
running in the morning you're hanging
out all night you get an hour to sleep
to go run that's what the you can get
some [ __ ] don't abuse it
but just don't chase it yeah chasing is
worse than getting it's like this like
it's like the root of the root of all
evil is not it's it's not money it's the
greed the grieve oh yeah you know what
i'm saying
that that's what the not getting the
chasing is what gets your ass kicked
that's a fact chasing it because your
mind is just somewhere else so you
getting you calm your light get that no
whoo god thank god you have to do that's
ready right
let's get this [ __ ] now baby
people say you tired if you guys know
you
oh this [ __ ] getting this dick boy
i don't know why people say that made
you weak that's not a lie that's a some
old remedy cell yeah if a guy can
control you from [ __ ] he could make
you do anything
yeah
that's gonna make you weak
jesus
but i will say this mike even to me as a
fighter
oh no man i'll be getting sleepy son i
get sleepy you know i mean especially if
it's an aggressive drawing you know what
i mean no you don't look at it like that
it's got that number let's see how i'm
gonna rip this [ __ ]
i'm an egomaniac when it comes to that
yeah
i look at it like i look at it like oh
you don't look
and that's why i be holding on
they getting hit but like i just i just
don't release all the time i'm just
talking see my wife would kick my
[ __ ]
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] for the raiders
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but keep that in though
okay i'm talking [ __ ] about the rating
damn the no fat community gonna come
after you mike no fat no fap you ever
heard of that community tell me about
that just like seeming retention no fap
it's like this whole new thing oh my god
no fat like don't fat don't beat you me
why didn't they say that was self that
was safe sex before remember
remember the surgeon general you
remember that but jerk it off then she
said the black lady be harder get the
lady that's saying right now
masturbation
masturbation healthy surgeon general
said masturbate
to prevent aids and yeah come on
masturbation i was in the 90s and [ __ ]
because i know i'm not lying [ __ ]
there's a new time though like with this
new generation is is a lot of like you
know girls in general black lady who's
pushing the you know anti-porn [ __ ]
because they saying the porn [ __ ]
[ __ ] mine's almost like chasing [ __ ]
yeah blood
you run listen peep game know what it's
like it's like you're a rap it's like
you on the um the treadmill in your mind
you keep running you're running and
you're running and you never get the
[ __ ] whatever you want you just keep
running your mind is just gone
keep running
though it's like
what did you hear about this or why did
this come to mind for you what with like
the retention system because like you
know with boxing like i've i've heard it
a lot like seeming retention related to
fighters you know what i mean like like
i've heard that throughout time like
fighting they hold on to their it
doesn't make sense they make you
stronger holds on your testosterone i
feel like it does make you angry mike it
makes you mean as a [ __ ] yeah
doesn't make you better no
yeah that's her name and she's still
alive she ain't like god that's gonna
drink some liquor son
keep going
that's true too though go ahead
maybe type in her name next to
masturbation yeah that would be awesome
i remember i was young she was saying
masturbation
masturbate masturbate bastard
[Laughter]
no no i don't i don't believe in that
[ __ ] man i don't believe in spilling
your own messes i mean you know i ain't
judging nobody but you know just to each
his own me i'd rather hold on to my [ __ ]
damn what you talking about to get this
chick for encouraging masturbation
a black woman said that [ __ ] nothing
[ __ ]
teaching children about masturbation
might reduce safe unsafe sex yes she
replied i think that it's something that
is a part of human sexuality and it's
part of something that perhaps should be
taught but we've not even taught our
children the very basics damn that's
what she said uh-huh
what do y'all think about that i ain't
no [ __ ] you only could jerk off so
long
you know yeah every day i gotta jerk off
and come on i know it's okay one day
that's two days but not every [ __ ]
day i gotta jerk off
i mean you're definitely tired after all
of that [ __ ]
oh man so tell us more man what you got
planned man you have any children man
yeah i got i got one
um three years old what's the name she's
girl in the goraine
my baby girl three going on 13. that's a
beautiful brother beautiful calling my
little she's a three nature is what i
call it
[ __ ] but yeah um not trying to have any
more anytime soon you never know only
god could decide that's a fact that is a
fact i mean god definitely decided for
me yeah and i have a next presidency you
don't want no kids [ __ ] you say what
man the next president you don't you
don't want no more kids sheesh if
somebody could be pregnant right now you
know
that's why i'd be trying to hold on mike
i'm trying to tell you
listen
you can only do that for a certain
amount of time so you have to get as
much out as you can
but it's not going to work forever
certain amount of time i mean [ __ ] to
each his own you know
i plan on living for a long time that's
awesome you dig
but you know god's will god willing yeah
you know what i'm saying just a
beautiful world out here i don't think
that's as bad as they might think it is
because i'm saying how could life be
beautiful death is bad right and you
know people who make a mistake saying
you only live once you actually live
every day you only die once yeah
yes
and then when we die we're gonna live
some more
i can't yes
i just can't see this essence just going
boom black that's what i'm saying like i
feel i feel like you know back to my
point i feel like earth is a school for
your soul right and it's like if you
don't learn the lesson that you're
supposed to for your soul
somehow you get sent back
you know what i mean like like like you
get
your energy or your essence gets sent
back to the people let's think about
this one then that's a cool one too but
think about this
no really really i just thought about
this you just think like it's like in
the weeds somewhere place with some
weeds and stuff and um it's getting
colder now so all the plants are dying
that's what we are and certain time
we're gonna all die
and then we get back in the grounds away
and some [ __ ] some mud and [ __ ] gonna go
down to him we're gonna be made again
born by another woman a man you know
just we're like plants we die and we
come back for season and then there's
also like you know what what like
i'm not a scientist so i know you are
you
for sure what what was before the big
bang theory
was there a forum listen that's what
we're all afraid to say who are we who
are we who you think you think am i
really my mother's child do you think
i'm really my mother's child
now who's my who is my
my millionaire's mother
you know i mean
where is my my millionth grandmother
wouldn't we all have the same one you
know what i'm saying like it's time oh
no no no we're all related all of us in
here is one all of us are related
listen even though they wrote you we
were there during the trojan world every
war we were all together we always there
was no time that somebody was there we
weren't there we were all together even
if we were different races then we were
always together right yeah heard up
so we haven't been learning our lesson
because we still here
and those are the questions we have
right mike what uh what
our minds our minds our mind it wasn't
made to even fathom god
you know we could say god i love we
could but our mind is not even
sophisticated enough to even fathom what
god is that's a fact but we think we
know
yeah we know god loves me
yeah god you know i mean even the
personification of god right you know
what i'm saying like you're talking to
god as if like he's a person or
or if it's a he is she like no god um
god has to be a woman
god has to be a woman who gave birth
creator you have to be a woman i mean i
just i think god is is just like a force
it's like an energy whatever force is a
female force for sure for no absolutely
the female four definitely feminine
physics why do you say that though mike
why do you see that or what makes you
say that because they give birth to us
to our seeds
they they take over our seeds even
though we're the man we put the see they
take over i see they form our seeds
women are portals yeah you know
poor eat them
but my only thing is if god is a woman
who impregnated god huh
if god is a woman what impregnated god
god right another god another god the
gods that's so something like we keep
living and god will keep creating we
keep dying this is not gonna stop
creating or not it's just a cycle when
the end of the world is gonna be put
that in there when is the end of the
world gonna be
when's the end of the world going to be
conspiracy you know the way i think it's
um you know we can see it but look i
have a thing where have the time go by
and have the world blow up and explode
looks crazy
yeah
was it on youtube yeah
the end of the world
but the end of the world
nine years yeah but they said twenty-two
that's what it looks like at the end of
the world say end of the world oh no i'm
saying this with the world look like
it's the end of the world
new york city it's gonna be like pretty
much underwater by the 2030s
[ __ ]
they ain't gonna drown new york
skoda's just
just take over jersey dude yeah right
how many trillion years before the earth
has come to an end i thought that they
was really crazy watching the numbers go
and i was saying we're dead and i'm
saying my grandkids are dead i said a
great great grandkids are dead because
tommy is going numbers numbers yeah
we all gonna die
ten thousand years is going down
thousands to show us the um
the photo of it the tape
i feel like it's gonna happen before
that
on youtube the planet keeps going around
straight ahead brother straight ahead on
your right hand side
yeah of course man mike what advice you
got for for joey
just never give up on anything always
believe in yourself how do you measure
an opportunity um i measured by my
performance
i make my own opportunities
opportunities come to me when they see
my determination my will to conquer it
and that's what that's just what life is
like no but i'm saying when the
opportunity approaches you how do you
measure like like how do you know if
it's for you if it's not for you how do
you know to take it on or to not take it
off well listen i'm at the stage in my
life right now where i know everything
that's gonna work for me
i don't know if if i'm at the stage
where i'm um i need your fighting i
don't know that much about this
particular
part of my life i'm gonna get some help
from someone what is your favorite
mistake
my favorite mistake yeah [ __ ] being born
that's a mistake you think yeah yeah but
that wasn't your mistake no i had
nothing to do with it
well you did beat all the other sperm
cells yeah so maybe that was a mistake i
didn't want to be here somebody else
wanted me to you should have slowed down
man i couldn't
they were pushing me from the back
pushing hard from the back
[Music]
they're trying to go there
that's what's up joy what you got for
all the fans men out there
look at there's millions of people
looking at you man don't even know who
you are that know you now
joey badass man um you know
anything is possible you know what i'm
saying
dare to dream as big as you can because
you set the parameters on which you can
achieve things in life
like i'm sitting here with mike [ __ ]
tyson right now ain't no [ __ ] the glory
goes to god no that's real [ __ ] though
hold up i mean [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
face tag tribal title no [ __ ] check it
out right
so my friends right they they was back
in the day they were slinging
and they they got down back in the day
so you know we hang out and stuff and
they said mike man
you know um
we we will have pride hanging out with
you because you're the champion you're a
celebrity but your [ __ ] wreck is
worse than ours man like if the police
look at my regular whole [ __ ] who's this
guy
doesn't look like the big
mike tyson anybody likes you know i had
to deal with life early
it wasn't fun circumstantial yeah
but i survived things that i survived
would kill other people i always look at
life like that
i'm not one of the guys that um
that gave up and it's easy to give up
because this [ __ ] is hard to maintain
it's actually the hard part is to give
up yeah that's when the real [ __ ] gets
real nah it's easy to give up dude you
getting up to either thing it's so easy
to give up bro you just busting that and
it's all right yeah
i'm done go to school you gotta want to
be up more than anybody in the world
want you to be down it's the complete
the fight period i have nobody else to
fight i'll find the [ __ ] to
fight period and it's like you know when
you up too it's like you got to remember
not to say that nobody don't want you up
but like you got to keep yourself dead
but you know there's times you got to go
down too you got to handle going down
just as much just as good as your handle
going up murder it's like it's like it's
like kobe said if you can win
championships in front of the world you
should be able to [ __ ] take off lose
the playoffs you know what i'm saying
set over from the playhouse for the rest
of the world
let us have it joey tell all the fans
man you have you have what what is it a
hundred million people mike
there's a lot of people like can i just
one more question yes
what's your take on dreams on dreams
dreams do you dream a lot i used to when
i was younger but now you smoke so much
blood no uh i manifest now
i don't dream anymore everything i do is
manifest they're better than dreams too
they come quicker as well
not like not like dreams in the sense of
like oh i'm dreaming i want to be this
one day i'm too like actually when you
sleep and then you're going that's not
like dude that doesn't happen what only
when i do the toad that happens where i
i go to another planet another dimension
i know i don't sleep no more i well i
don't dream i know i don't even remember
it's no dream like i just told i've been
a lot of [ __ ] happen or whatever i know
i don't dream
very real go to sleep and get a dream
very rare well you know
if you smoke we feel bad you ain't gonna
dream no that's right mm-hmm you smoke
before bed that smoke sativa so i'm up
that's how i do this that's what i smoke
when i do i can't go to sleep
television i'm looking at [ __ ] all night
long [ __ ] i just start smoking it's
been like a week it's been a week for me
yeah it looks like stopping every now
and then yeah exactly that's what i do i
take a little four month break that's
what we do it's not right all this stuff
you know we abuse it
you know it's not meant to be abused and
the thing is i smoke with tobacco like
the robber uh-huh why didn't you have
hash in there
not hash is just i like the way it hit
like i can't i can't i can't do the hash
with the but i have to smoke the
cigarettes too with the hash you got to
show the cigarettes with you i can't
smoke the weed this is not that i'm
saying i can't smoke weed by itself nah
i can't do that [ __ ] i can't do weed
with hats it just doesn't taste good oh
you know not hats
together the back of the tobacco hash is
meant together
it's just not right you just don't go
together but you smoke weed just by
itself yes
with the
tobacco oh [ __ ] mike tyson yeah thank
you
for having me
i appreciate that man much love
yeah well there you have it dude you see
joey
[ __ ] ass joey thank you for joining
us you guys just watching the episode of
hot boxing with mike tyson i'm your
co-host aka triple c henry cejudo and
i'm mike tyson and we're here with joey
badass from brooklyn and thank you again
brother for blessing us thank you
pleasures on mine tyler
[Music]
you